hello everyone and welcome back to the
Magnus Invitational we are continuing
the match Maxim Varsha lagravis is an
opponent in their game one that we've
covered yesterday Maxime 1 and the next
two games and ended in a draw so here an
echo is in a must-win situation with the
black pieces if he wants to get back
into the match and force and Armageddon
well before we check out this game I
would just like to briefly mention this
position this is a game cross and versus
future that we've covered and a lot of
you mentioned that okay queen g6 Czech
Bishop captures pawn captures his mate
but what if Bishop to g8
you said that maybe you can defend like
this because then the King has DHH where
it's also a problem because after Queen
g6 check King moves you don't have Queen
captures here because you will not be
able to deliver mate using this rook
since it's pinned but you do have a
queen to f7 and next move its mate
there's nothing a magnitude could have
done here there are no checks there
there's no rogue d3 there's no Queen h1
there's nothing here
so next get a next movie Fallujah would
just deliver checkmate on g8 so that
being said let's check out this game so
neppo in a must-win situation let's see
what he chooses with efore by maxime and
nipple goes for c5 the Sicilian defense
we have Knight to f3 d6 and Bishop to b5
check the canal attack we have Knight to
d7 blocking and now c3 preparing to
strike in the center would be 4 we have
Knight to f6 and now comes bishop back
to d3 defending the pawn this way
preparing bishop to c2 now to make room
for the deep on with g6 and now we have
castles by Maxine will rush of the g7
rook to e1 and now black also castles
push it back to c2 and there is one game
where a 6 was played preparing b5 but
here and nipple just goes for b5
straight away and it is as a move 8 that
we have a completely new game so Maxine
continues with d4 and brush-up the b7
just putting pressure on d4 pawn we have
d5 closing up the center and rook to e8
now with a 4 challenging this Queen side
expansion and
a six neppo defense we have Bishop to f4
now grabbing control of the e5 square
and night to the h5 net nipple kicks the
bishop back Bishop to e3 and now Knight
the b6 hoping to maybe get the night
over to c4 but also it will be just
useful at some point you want to play e6
and the tag the central d5 pawn so
Knight bTW to getting the night into the
game and east six now so the captures
nipple captures with the rook and now we
have a few characters here captures
captures the rooks also come off the
board rook captures Queen captures and
now now as there's a lot of pressure
here against this pawn here first Bishop
to b3 you force the rook to move away
you kind of hope to get c4 in which were
the favored white as you would grab grab
the d4 square for your knight
so Luke just back to e7 and now h3 I
just preparing g4 to keep a kick away
tonight with Knight to d7 and now this
night is coming to have six to put more
pressure on the e4 pawn and now Russia
back to c2 to immediately help out with
the defense with h6 and now Queen to a
one
maxime only needs a draw so he doesn't
mind the Queen's coming off the board if
he gets a draw he wins the match so rook
to e8 nipple decides that he's going to
trade it this way as it will allow him
at some point to go for this B to pawn
so g4 attacking the knight Knight f6 and
now comes in Bishop therefore going
after the d6 pawn but instead of
defending nipple just the counters with
rook to a2 and okay rook the b1 maxime
defense and now Knight the EA to just
defending the d6 pawn with Bishop to b3
attacking the rook here and rogue back
to Asics guarding the d6 pawn and now
nip own can again bring the knight back
into the game we have c4 but nipple of
course doesn't want to trade he creates
his nice punch in here and makes this
bishop a bit bit useless for the moment
whereas a nepos bishop pair is a fully
operational here just slicing the board
in half nicely both bishops having
targets so that's how that's how you
should use your bishops we have Knights
the e1 now shifting the night
over the d3 where it will help out with
the defense of the beach upon and night
to c7 now the night is coming to e6 so
Bishop to e3 and night the e6 just just
the same with f3 now as strengthening
the e4 pawn but you will create some
dark squares around around your King
here so you should consider not trading
off your dark square bishop so nice the
d4 with that idea that if Bishop
captures it will just be a great
position for black so butter back to d1
just keeping an eye on this night here
guarding everything and now as the best
removed finally looked back to 8 you
going again for this pawn here if the
knight moves then the bishop and the
rook will will go after the pawn so
tonight the d3 adding another defender
here and the knight back to c6 now and
here Maxime decided to go for f4 taking
away the e5 square from Naples Knights
but now Knepper just returns with Knight
the d4 with King F - Maxime improves the
position of the King and now Knight to
f6 again putting pressure on the e4 pawn
so Maxime forwards it with E 5 with
night that efore with check and you
don't want to trade here if you trade
here it doesn't really work all that
well for you because your knight is
under attack and once you defend it you
can just grab a free pawn here since the
knight cannot recapture because of well
the rook would be hanging on b1 so here
we have King to e 1 but now just D
characters on e5 with F captures on e5
and now Knight backed up East 6 adding
another defender here we have Knight to
b3
now adding another attacker here and
nipple just defended Bishop back to f8
and here finally rook to a 1 Maxime is
able to trade off this pesky rook we
have rook captures Knight captures and
now comes Bishop the a6 never goes for
the c4 pawn now not interested in
committing with b3 at the moment the
first Bishop to f3 a nice counter-attack
as the knight is undefended
Knight to g5 attacking and defending and
now Fischer back to G 2 and this Bishop
the g2 by maksim isn't all that all that
great better was at a trade off one of
the night
that's what he should have done probably
a capture sign g5 night chapters and
then Bishop to d5 regard the c5 pawn and
after nepo grabs this one then you go
here and grab the c5 pawn well of course
that's easier said than done
maximum when the bishop to g2 and here
we have the characters on c4 by nipple
and now Knight to f4 so what do you do
here we here a nipple went for a knight
the g3 we have Bishop to f2 attacking
the knight once again and mountain night
5 2 y 4 and here we have the incredible
Bishop captures and g3 Knight captures
and King f2 reaching our position from
the thumbnail and the knight is trapped
here you cannot escape all of these
squares are covered d2 squared twice by
the knight and by the king so what do
you do here it seems like you're
completely lost now however it's neppo
is who has the advantage here but only
if you play the only move that gives you
advantage so feel free to pause the
video here and try to find it this only
move for net but while I give you a
couple of seconds so for those of you
who were able to do it congratulations
as its it's not an easy move to find and
for those of you who just want to enjoy
the show it's a Bishop to g7 and now
what's the idea well you have to give up
the night but now comes Bishop
characters on e5 and now White has to
unpin unless he wants to give back
material after g5 is played so King to
f3 by maksim and now b3 not allowing the
knight any escapes with Knight - see -
and now bunch of characters and b2 is
coming so here you can't really do much
for example if you try to rush rush over
there with the King King III you just
get either Bishop captures and b2 b2
right away or just checking the two now
you can capture and now there is no
escaping so here you would have to give
up and the night and well the two
bishops control these four squares and
the point is just marching forward so
here instead after b3 maxime tried
Bishop to f1 he wants to trade bishops
so he can get his knight into the game
via Knight captures on b3 and okay
Bishop captures we have Knight captures
and now Bishop back to d6 so
in bag the piece and the defending the
c-5 point now we have Knights to d2 and
Bishop just goes goes back a preparing
to ship the bishop over to c6
so b3 and King to g7 our neighbor starts
bringing his King into the game we have
King the e3 and now Bishop the c6 we
have night the d3 and now comes f5 now
that the two bishops are nicely slicing
all the way here
nipple creates a passed pawn so we have
G characters and G captures and now
after things have settled down a bit
after all that madness
it's neppo who has the bishop pair
against the two knights and he has his
up upon so and the maxime needs to hold
this if he wants to win the match with
night the c-4 going after the bishop now
bishop here just shifting the bishop
over to this King side Knight f4 and now
Knepper just pins the night we have
Knight to e5 going after the bishop
Bishop to b5 now and Knight to f3 now
going after the bishop we have King to
f7 and the trading here not really doing
all that much as you will just fix
black's pawn structure
so instead 95 check we have King to have
six and again Knight back to f3 now by
mvl a st. na po that you're the one who
has to figure out a plan here Bishop the
c6 and the napadas have a plan if nepo
just trades everything then the King and
pony and game is winning as Black is up
upon so here i'm maxeen play Knight
captures and g5 which which basically
fixes the the pawn structure but it's
hard to find a move you can't move the
point you can't move the King as you
lose the night it's really hard to find
you could try Knight - D - but then you
seemingly run into this and and and it
looks like you're going to lose the
night however night c4 check kicks the
King Bank and maybe you can just repeat
so black would have to figure out a way
here however maxime traded here and now
those are two very strong connected
pawns and went for a knight to d3 he
goes after the c5 pawn and trades a dh3
pawn for its own nipple goes for it
Bishop g2
we have h4 here if you just trade a
knight Knight captures Bishop captures
then it's still to connect the passed
pawns
so here MBL at least breaks them up so G
captures on h4 and only now Knight
captures on c5 and hopefully maxime will
also start pushing his own past pawn
king g5 and now comes King to f2
attacking the bishop but Bishop to d5 we
were before and came to g4 now we have
Knight to b3 now probably hoping for
some like here to defend the b5 score
but then Knight Rick's picks up the
bishop so you have to be a little bit
careful with f4 by nipple and Knight to
e5 with king f5 kicks away the knight
Knight back to d3 and now Bishop the e4
again if you if you you cannot trade it
and pieces as it still it's two against
one
so nice the c5 moving moving away and
now h3 and here pink the g1 you cannot
allow this pawn to reach the h2 square
as the bishop is covering the queening
square so f 3 and now b5 and here you it
seems like f to check followed by h2 is
winning however this would be a blunder
if you tried this and h2 now just Knight
captures on e4 and you just wonder the
game well it's a draw but you blunder
the win because you either capture and
then you allow King g2 or you bring a
queen enter game and then Knight g3
check King has to move and then he just
pick up the Queen and it's a drawn in
game now so after b5 nipple not
interested in wandering this king of
four first not allowing this in between
93 trick so b6 and now f2 width check
King captures and h2 and it was in this
position that Maxine bascillica resigned
the game nape was back in the match and
he forces the Armageddon now if 93 check
for example of course you don't capture
kingi - just move the King away and
whatever white plays next you just you
just queen and that's it so that's the
game I do hope you enjoyed it but we're
also gonna show the Armageddon game as
it's extremely short it basically ends
in the opening so I decided not to make
a separate video on it after the coin
toss
it's Maxime again who grabs it the white
pieces and now Maxime has five minutes
in Armageddon nipple has formed but
Maxime has to win so Maxime again goes
for efore he obviously like the position
he got but neppo does not go for the
Sicilian instead nipple goes for a five
and here our game starts night of three
and nipple goes for the Petrov defense
night of six we have night captures on
d5 d6 and Knight goes back so the
classical variation Knight captures on
e4 and d3 Knight goes back with d4 and
d5 so this is the the mainest of lines
with Bishop to d3 and Bishop to d6 so
just developing we need to check Bishop
to e6 and Knight to g5 going after the
bishop here Queenie 7 and now captures
on e6 with F captures and c3 and this is
also one of the games that was played in
the candidates tournament between
Alexandria shook and Wang how that ended
in a draw
where Grisha went for c5 here but here
we have castles by Napo and now
obviously we have a completely new game
already at move 11
so with f4 Maxime grabs a hold of the e5
square with ideas of shifting this
Knight over to e5 at some point and now
c5 by nipple challenging the center with
castles and now Knight to c6 both are
just continued development Bishop to e3
rook 88 and now a nice study - with the
idea of 15 the night over to e5 but now
nipple goes for e5 he finds this secret
tactic that allows him to grab the
initiative right from the start we have
D captures by by maksim and now Knight
captures just offering up a full night
the problem is if you capture and
capture then there's the threat of Queen
captures and h2 and also just winning
back the piece so you don't really you
don't really have a good move
and if you try blocking with the Sun
like Bishop to a four then you just grab
the Queen Queen captures Bishop captures
and then you pick up the bishop on an f4
again attacking the knight and there's
also the bishop that's under attack so
here you would see captures captures and
at the end of this a very long line we
would have this position where it's just
a much better for black black is up a
pawn and well your knight is under
attack once you defend it you get to
look after eight and it's it's a really
bad position for for white to play
however and the maxime decided not to go
for it instead he went for Bishop to b5
for the for the rook he didn't like the
endgame there arises from this and now
you get Knight eat the g4 just going
with a triple attack on the bishop
we have Bishop captures any eight rook
captures and now there's well just a lot
of pressure on this Bishop here also we
cannot move it as the Queen would hang
so rook f3 but now just Knight
characters on III by nipple here wrote
the a one and neppo just went back nice
to a5 and it was in this position that
Maxine washer allograph resigned the
game and thus never won the Armageddon
point is you have two pieces for a rook
and you have to play something and
there's not much you cannot avoid the
Queen trade you have to trade here
captures captures and now it's just a
bishop and in the night for a rook and
Maxime is not interested in in playing
this against nip oh he's very sure that
nipple will win this and it doesn't
really make much sense and plus the
Napalm he needs a draw to win the
Armageddon so Maxime just resigned here
or maybe they agreed to a draw I don't
know maybe maybe my seams just offer to
draw and but doesn't really matter as it
also wins the match so that's also the
game I do hope you enjoyed that as well
hope you don't mind that I squeezed two
games into one video as it's really too
short just to make a separate video for
it and here are the standings after they
for round two so here they are in first
place sharing Magnus Carlsen and Fabiano
Caruana with four points Nakamura Moxon
virtually grab ending lira and with two
points and polishing and
Alireza fuchsia and an injury with zero
points so far
so there you have it it's gonna be it's
gonna be a wild well around three so
we'll see how that goes
we have a big big matchup here Hikaru
Nakamura will face all it as a future so
IIIi think that that's definitely going
to be enjoyable and also Magnus faces
Caruana but I think that's that's
tomorrow so those are the games or
rather those were the games I do hope
you enjoyed them I would like to thank
the friends is call Richard Schwartz
Thomas Connors Donald Pettingill and
William McKay for a contribution to my
channel thank you a lot I really
appreciate it as usual you can check to
my previous videos serum think of for
watching and I will see you soon
continuing the coverage of the Magnus
Invitational until it finishes so thank
you all I will see you soon and have an
excellent rest of your day